there are 20 things that you propose men
should look for be aware of be privy to
in regards to women and I'd love to go
through each one of them briefly with
you the very first red flag which is the
term we hear all the time but maybe I
maybe guys people don't understand what
it means red flag number one is avoid a
woman with daddy issues what exactly
does that mean
yeah so if a woman doesn't have a good
relationship with a strong virtuous man
in her life ideally her father maybe if
her father passed on when she was small
grandfather or an uncle
then she's often going to have a fear of
Abandonment tied into things like
borderline personality disorder and they
often act out in such a way that ensures
that awful things happen
um one of the things that I strongly
recommend guys do when vetting a woman
for anything on a long-term basis
whether it's dating or to raise children
together is make sure you're dealing
with a woman that has a good
relationship with her dad so some people
get mad at that you know they'll say
well my dad was a bum or he ran off or
you know whatever the story may be and I
always encourage people to try and
contact your father you know if he's
still around and get to the story before
you believe you know the narrative that
might have been sold to you by some of
the women in your family
um he might have been an alright guy and
he might have got pushed out of the
household and he might want to have a
relationship with you so
um it's something to to consider and
understand and if a woman's doing the
work on it you know she's going through
some form of therapy to deal with
whatever Daddy issues you might have or
resentments you might have towards men
anger any of those things cool
um it's definitely a red flag but you
want to pay attention to it and be aware
of it
it's a really good point you know I
would go one step further and ask what
about girls that have dads that made
them into princesses right daddy's
little girl could never do any raw she
adores daddy
um doesn't have any problems with Dad
but Dad was kind of a you know a
pushover
how do we spot that in a woman where
does that kind of show up in her
personality so that we can say hey she
loves her dad yeah but her dad's yeah
you know a daughter sin
yeah that's a good point so a pushover
dad is the kind of guy that she will run
as she's an adult so give an example I
got a friend that's uh married a very
successful professional woman uh fathers
in the picture has always been in the
pictures you know he's a good dude you
know he's a nice guy
um you know he's a uh
he he's your quintessential uh Robert
Glover nice guy right
um and there's a difference between a
nice guy and a kind man you know you
guys can dig through that when you get
to Robert Glovers No More Mr Nice Guy
book
um but because Mom ran him in the
household and he was
um he was basic I mean I want to use the
word slave but he behaved a lot like a
slave he's at her beck and call for
every single thing I mean she's an adult
woman she's in her 30s he's in his
retirement years he's not in the best of
health but when she says jump he says
how high I need a picture hung shows up
and does it need a Chandler put together
shows up and does it
um these these pushover men rest assured
um it's another version of daddy issues
uh she's gonna try to pull that with you
in a long-term relationship or a
marriage she's going to try to run you
yeah okay so number two is feminists and
this is a tough one because you know
it's it's hard to find a woman that
doesn't
that isn't a feminist at least that is
conscious level So when you say feminist
what exactly do you mean and you know
what are some of the things that we can
look for to spot that in a you know
there no work way
yeah I mean the overt signs have become
pretty obvious now purple hair
overweight covered in tattoos like a
sticker book you know in random places
um these are the kind of gals that
subscribe to beliefs uh which require
them to be a victim okay and if you're a
victim in an equation you have to have
an oppressor you have to be you have to
have somebody that's doing you wrong
well the oppressor happens to be men for
them and I think feminism had Noble
roots in its cause where it was looking
for equality but I don't think many
people today would argue that there's
that there's things that women can't do
that men are doing you know
um there's some people that say oh well
women are still getting paid 70 or 80
cents on the dollar for every dollar
that a man makes but they're not taken
into
the fact that men work more dangerous
jobs longer hours there's pushes to put
women in the boardroom for Fortune 500
companies but there's no pushes to put
women on the back of garbage trucks or
coal mines or oil rigs those are all
predominantly jobs done by men and they
pay a lot more because they're longer
hours and more dangerous so it it's a
bit of a lie and I think at this point
you know it's been said a few times now
by several different people it's not in
a quality movement anymore it's more of
a Supremacy movement looking for the
subjugation and the uh bending of the
knee to all women because of past
manufactured traumas in many cases
um it's just not good to be in a
long-term relationship with any woman
that has a victim mindset as a baseline
like as a foundation because victims are
just awful to be around they never take
ownership for everything it's always
somebody else's fault if you have any
disagreements in that relationship it's
always going to be your fault there's
there's going to be no ownership taken
on her part
so you you mentioned that maybe feminism
had Noble roots
um tell me more about that you know
because there are those who argue that
there's no such thing as good feminism
and if we're you know saying that
refraining from the victim mindset is an
important thing here
um I'm curious how you how do you
reconcile that with there maybe being a
good feminism yeah well there's an
example that I use in my book actually
um I think it was in the 1800s I can't
remember the exact date but there was a
lot passed in London that prevented you
from beating your wife after a certain
after nine o'clock at night I think it
was and the roots of it really weren't
to protect women it was because of noise
pollution issues and they didn't want to
hear their neighbors beating their wives
while her while she was screaming sort
of thing so they so they kind of started
to adopt these things it's like well why
are we beating women I think that's a
reasonable thing like you know why are
we beating women right like is that
absolutely necessary
okay right yeah I can see that number
three
the unhappy and unlucky
so um you know why would you want to
stay stay away from an unhappy woman
oh yeah the unhappy The Unlucky woman
well she's going to come home for work
she's going to be complaining about the
part-timer that shows up late uh doesn't
do her job properly she has to pick up
the slack
um just just everything you know there
was that acronym that that popped up
about 20 years ago in my life was FML
and that basically stood for f My Life
um the unhappy unlucky will go to that
all the time I'm just always unlucky I'm
on unlucky in love I'm unlucky I can't
lose weight I'm unlucky and I can't I
place an offer on the house that I
wanted I didn't get it it's like nothing
ever goes their way and it's and it's
this big cloud of negative energy that's
around them they're like energy vampires
they will suck the joy and happiness
from your life they're just so sad to be
around
um I think it's one of Robert Robert
Greene's uh 48 rules of um or 48 Laws of
Power yeah staying away from people that
are that are are in that mindset
it's just better it's not just exclusive
to women I think it's exclusive to human
beings in general stay away from people
that are unlucky
and always unhappy about something yeah
you know I see this sometimes I think
you do make reference to it but there
you know someone listening might say why
would anybody want to hang out with
someone who's unlucky unhappy but there
tends to be this Instinct within some
men I I think we all have it how it
shows up is different but to then save
this poor soul uh what do you say to men
that are attracted to these poor souls
so that they can you know potentially
lift them up
yeah I think men inherently want to
protect and save women so you know they
call this Dynamic the Captain Save A Hoe
Dynamic and the Mano swamp
um which is you know just a funny way of
of sort of putting it putting it because
a lot of these women they're that's just
who they are right
um it's it's it's part of our nature as
men to want to protect weaker women you
know weaker beings you know like weaker
beings this is why we accept refugees
into you know certain countries uh based
on their story or their never narrative
why they're leaving this is why we send
food to starving children in Africa when
they show us those videos on TV because
we want to protect we want to preserve
we want to better things and women are
just part and parcel of that so
um the thing that men need to understand
is I think you have to set strong and
firm boundaries around you and the
people outside of Your Inner Circle
because if you invite the wrong person
into your life you can complicate it
unnecessarily so so being being a kind
man is good
being a nice guy that's a pushover
that's more of a Captain Save A Hoe
that's where you run into problems this
is where you're running trying to save
women or you get guys that will wife up
a gal that's got four kids from three
different fathers a whole bunch of debt
you know like these guys swoop in
routinely and will give up their life
savings and their opportunity to Father
their own children to raise Another
Man's children and and bail her out it's
very common I really hope you guys
enjoyed that clip if you want to watch
the full-length podcast you can find
that over here that clips from if you're
new to the channel make sure you hit
subscribe over here and pin down below
in the top comment you'll find a bunch
of useful links to my website my
supplement line books and a bunch of
other stuff have an amazing day peace
out